Alex how much are you sacrificing your
own Hollywood goals to be so heavily
involved with FII films or did you never
have hollywood quote-unquote Hollywood
goals
yeah I have goals that are in alignment
with what how Hollywood perceive success
but I don't feel like I'm sacrificing
anything because I feel like this is my
organic journey to being a filmmaker so
I went to USC where we were very much
taught a Hollywood way of filmmaking
you know meson saying master shot medium
close up close up ECU cutaway you know
and in working with the youth they're
very informal like they don't like to
lock the camera down on the tripod
because they are locked up they they're
very inventive like one day I came to
the camp and they attached three bungee
cords on each side of the camera said
hey money look it's a bungee camp and
the cameras moving and they're very
inventive and so the way I was taught
filmmaking was to take a very stately
formal Hollywood approach the youth in
working with the youth it liberated me
from that and I become more radical in
my approach to storytelling through
cinema I crossed the line we told never
crossed the sagittal plane well I do all
the time now because they youth
emboldened me so I feel like my work
with them is a necessary part of my
journey I feel like my work as a
filmmaker is informed by my interactions
and my making films with them the other
thing they like is they don't like
having to memorize lines and repeat
lines because it's too robotic for them
so before we should have seen with them
they'll say this is what's happening in
the scene you want her to agree to date
you and you are saying no that is my
sister you're not dating her you don't
want it and I just freestyle it in three
improv so it's made me a little bit more
relaxed I use their proposition a lot I
didn't before I started working with
this pie
galician a more relaxed in and in less
formal and it's interesting because when
I when I place Sony Pictures
Entertainment they support us and they
give us cameras and when we give cameras
to the youth the first thing they do is
they point cameras back at the
surveillance cam saying I see you you're
watching me but I'm watching you watch
me you know they take control the
apparatus and they turn the tables but
when they're filming
they'll I'll say go to what interview
they'll go to where the emotion is like
if there's a scene between a son and an
actor's who's the mother crying to go in
to the tear drop going down the mother's
eye and it's a very organic approach
they go to where they feel the emotional
power is what what is interesting the
scene oh the mother really feels bad
that she wasn't the mother she should
have been the first 14 years of his life
and it's it's a necessary part making me
a better filmmaker my work with him
informs my path so my next project it's
a feature film called make the moon that
was developed at Sundance years ago and
it's based on my my twin brother and I
growing up in San Jose and it focuses on
a mother who has two sons that are mixed
race I also have a sister and her
brother gonna focusing on my twin
brother and I for this but in this film
there are three young people that really
impressed me as actors one is young
woman from the youth manyu tribe two
others are from LA they're in the film
I'm casting them then there's six other
youth that are gonna work on the film
and I'm gonna pay them and they're gonna
learn what it's like to be on an
independent film set and they're gonna
continue to develop their skills as
filmmakers so this is in alignment with
both I am going after my Hollywood goal
making this feature film but I'm also
engaging formerly incarcerated youth so
I'm combining the two and my dream is to
I'm currently working on a plan I'd like
to open up a film academy in the next
three to five years and
the Film Academy would be kind of like
the homeboy industries of filmmaking to
ex-gang members youth who have been
affected by the foster care system youth
affected by the juvenile justice system
not only train them to work on on music
video commercial or TV sets or movie
sets but to create develop and make
their own content because they have a
different take on things so to me that
the real exciting stuff is happening in
the margins they're not part of
mainstream media they're not part of
mainstream society they have their own
secret called a language of how to tell
a story with film they don't do that
master shot medium close up close up
easy they'll just get the shot get the
shot it's out of her crime let's
move on you know and they they love that
they use their own language to to take
ownership like a slate they don't call
slate the slate they call it a shield
and I asked this kid Jimmy why do you
call it a shoot Oh Keith pullets come
through he could dodge the bullets a
company move when you move the cast and
the crew they call it in trans that's
when a youth is being transported from a
Correctional Facility to the court to go
to hear okay they don't see say quiet on
the same set they said they say quiet in
the ghetto or quiet on the burial and
they also said don't say it's mos just
say it's NFS null friggin sound so they
they come up with their own vernacular
and on language to allow them to take
ownership but it's this very informal
radical approach to filmmaking that
inspires me informs me so they're
actually helping me unlearn what USC
taught me which is very formal Hollywood
just because you're being taught that
doesn't mean that's the only way to make
films so my films I feel now are more
[Music]
alive and more expressive because I let
go some of that old-school training you
know they're very radical with the
camera they do things like turn it
upside down and do cartwheels with it
bust there's a chasing
and it's that type of approach that that
informs my current approach to
filmmaking just like you said that some
of the quote unquote not were students
but maybe most arms crossed resistant
turn out to be some of the best do you
think that's the same in quote
traditional film schools the some of the
worst students maybe you know in the
back man who is this and then actually
they tried to be the best yeah did you
know do you know a story about Jim
Morrison at USC sort of um yeah yeah he
did he did two films and people said you
haven't no you don't have one creative
molecule in your body what are you doing
here
he was making some I actually saw two of
the films they were in the USC archive
and they're really really interesting
and of course he went on to be in the
doors but you know I went to a film
school that was very entrenched in you
know traditional conventional Hollywood
film storytelling and what I'm trying to
express is that that's good it's
important to know that
but the youth offered a different
approach to filmmaking which I find much
more exciting and much more real and it
gets audiences to react more you know
they also don't believe in these
unrealistic fake they call it fake ass
delusional endings or everything's fine
because sometimes everything doesn't in
fine but you keep going one of my
students Fila said you know sometimes
things don't end well but maybe the next
situation will end well and you just
hope the things and well and you you
celebrated when stories and well I mean
they don't end well you think about what
happened and you learn from it and you
grow from it and you move on so in the
film as we do it they're not all these
you know neatly tied up endings because
that's not the way life is right it's
not sometimes things don't become
resolved no I know you might have a
fought with a cousin or a family member
and that you may spend the rest of your
life going back and forth thinking that
it's going to get there but it doesn't
that's what life is us trying to love
and be loved and also pay the bills and
feed ourselves and
experience warmth and joy right and get
yours genders yeah go to the Laemmle as
much as you can yes great movies yeah by
the way the lonely didn't ask to say
that but yeah they do have some great
movies and what the beauty of art house
cinema is that often times things don't
always there's an ambiguous empting or
it's not always perfect whereas other
theaters it might be more neatly tied up
and I could see how they would relate to
that there's a film to let you know
you've made a film called family
problems in um it was a young Latino man
who made a film about his mother who was
what they called a glass head addicted
to crystal meth and um one of the boys
Julio said him when you know this film
is about Allen's mom but he doesn't want
you to know but don't say anything said
ok I want so the next day Allen came up
to me and said him we know this film
about this mother who's addicted to meth
that's about Julio's mom but he doesn't
want you to know well both their mothers
were addicted to to meth and so we made
this film and in the film the boy is
begging the mother to go into rehab he
finally gets the courage to say mom
please go into rehab and she does go to
rehab in the film so both boys invited
their mothers to the film and I said if
you can fight your mothers to this film
it's really unfair if you don't tell
them what the film is about you have to
tell them because they might experience
shame they might experience rage
humiliation or anger you cannot drop a
bomb on your mom's we have to let them
know so I called their mothers and the
boys were on the phone with me I said
look this is what the film is about
are you comfortable seeing a film about
a young boy who wants his mom to go to
rehab
both agreed they wanted to watch the
film both went this is at the Sony
theaters saw the film broke down into
tears within 48 hours both mothers were
in rehab because it took a film made by
their sons and they saw there's
something mama mama I need you mama I
need you you need to stop using and you
need to go to rehab I love you no matter
what but I need you in my life I need a
mom
so the films not only affected
visual but also the family in the
community and so even things like that
the the films are so real so my demand
for authentic representation it's much
more pronounced because of my students I
don't like fake stuff this has no
resonance you know
you